Nelson Mandela closed a statement from
the doc saying i have fought against
white domination and I have fought
against black domination I've cherished
the ideal of a democratic and free
society in which all persons live
together in harmony and with equal
opportunities it is an ideal which I
hope to live for and to achieve but if
needs be it is an ideal for which I am
prepared to die and Nelson Mandela lived
for that ideal and he made it real he
achieved more than could be expected of
any man today has gone home we've lost
one of the most influential courageous
and profoundly good human beings that
any of us will share time with on this
earth he no longer belongs to us he
belongs to the ages through his fierce
dignity and unbending will to sacrifice
his own freedom for the freedom of
others Madiba transformed South Africa
and moved all of us his journey from a
prisoner to a president embodied the
promise that human beings and countries
can change for the better his commitment
to transfer power and reconcile with
those who jailed him set an example that
all humanity should aspire to whether in
the lives of nations or our own personal
lives the fact that he did it all with
grace and good humor and ability to
acknowledge his own imperfections only
makes the man that much more remarkable
as he once said I'm not a saint unless
you think of a saint as a sinner who
keeps on trying
I am one of the countless millions who
drew inspiration from nelson mandela's
life my very first political action the
first thing i ever did that involved an
issue or a policy or politics was a
protest against apartheid I would study
his words and his writings the day he
was released from prison gave me a sense
of what human beings can do when they're
guided by their hopes and not by their
fierce and like so many around the globe
I cannot fully imagine my own life
without the example that Nelson Mandela
set and so long as I live I will do what
I can to learn from him to gresham is
Michelle and his family Michelle and I
extend our deepest sympathy and
gratitude for sharing this extraordinary
man with us his life's work meant long
days away from those who loved in most
and I only hope that the time spent with
him these last few weeks brought peace
and comfort to his family to the people
of South Africa we draw strength from
the example of renewal and
reconciliation and resilience that you
made real a free South Africa at peace
with itself that's an example to the
world and that's Madiba's legacy to the
nation that he loved
we will not likely see the likes of
Nelson Mandela again so it falls to us
as best we can to for the example that
he set to make decisions guided not by
hate but by love never discount the
difference that one person can make to
strive for a future that is worthy of
his sacrifice for now let us pause and
give thanks for the fact that Nelson
Mandela lived a man who took history in
his hands and bent the arc of the moral
universe towards justice may God bless
his memory and keep him in peace